[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 sur TV
78 une émission depuis les universités
des mairies de l'Ouest parisien nous
sommes le mercredi 11 octobre voici les
titres c'est le rendez-vous des
collectivités des ivelines et des hautes
scènes les universités des mairies de
l'Ouest parisien se tenaient aujourd'hui
au pyramide du Port Marly près de 2000
participants parmi lesquels de nombreux
maires qui ont pu échanger et s'informer
sur des thématiques qui concernent les
élus au quotidien retour dans cette
édition zoom sur cette innovation
présente sur le territoire de ctins en
Eveline roads et le plus grand
simulateur de conduite immersive au
monde et se trouve au Technocentre à
guencour au sein d'un nouveau bâtiment
de 2300 m car le groupe Renault l'
inauguré il y a quelques jours il est
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO le vin est à l'honneur en en ce
moment dans les Yvelines jusqu'au 22
octobre les caves de Gal à
saint-sirlécole célèbrent la fête des
vendanges du côté du musée Lambinet à
Versailles une visite thématique est
proposée avec des dégustations de Grand
Cru français et puis l'invité du 78 en
2è partie d'émission retour aux
université des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien où une thématique était dans
toutes les têtes celle des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 et Jin 289 jours avant l'événement
alors que les Yvelines s'apprêtent à
recevoir plusieurs épreuves comment se
prépare ce rendez-vous mondial nous
recevrons Olivier de laffire conseiller
départemental délégué au sports et aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques dans
cette édition et il y a plusieurs
invités avec moi autour de de moi sur
sur ce plateau qui est installé ici au
cœur des pyramides du port Marle il y a
notamment aussi un journaliste de la
rédaction de tv78 michalel midoro
bonjour bonjour et bonsoir même puisque
il est 18h actuellement on va parler
avec vous notamment dans quelques
instants des informations du jour à
retenir alors il n'y a pas que l'univers
C et les universités des mairies de
l'Est parisien il a aussi d'autres
choses à retenir dans l'actualité vous
allez nous parler de quoi dans quelques
instants on parlera notamment de
Philippe guigen maire des clois qui a
saisi dans un courrier le président de
la République une lettre qu'on verra
dans quelques instants et je vais
présenter les autres personnes qui sont
autour de moi en plateau tout de suite
dans le
78 et je vous le disais tv78 s'est
délocalisé aujourd'hui aux pyramide du
port Marley à l'occasion des universités
des mairies de l'Ouest parisien c'était
donc toute la journée ici un rendez-vous
consacré aux collectivités des Yvelines
et des hautes scènes tv78 vous a proposé
tout au long de la journée et des
émissions thématiques sur ce qu'est le
rôle de maire d'élu aujourd'hui des
interviews aussi avec les personnalités
politiqu qui étit présente sur place sur
notre plateau se sont succédés par
exemple Pierre Bédier le président du
conseil départemental des Yvelines
Valéri pcrè la Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France ou encore ililbron Pivet
président de l'Assemblée nationale vous
pouvez d'ors et déjà revoir ses
émissions sur notre compte Youtube et
une opération pour laquelle tv78 s'était
associée à sciencep Saint-Germain en
lait des étudiants nous ont accompagné
tout au long de la journée pour
alimenter nos fils sur les réseaux
sociaux alors il y en a trois qui sont
avec nous en plateau je vais les
présenter il y a nadèj antoniali bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir nadèj il y a jeanan
manien donc sur ma gauche mais à droite
bonsoir et il y a également Alexandre
Perro bonsoir bonsoir alors vous avez
assisté vous trois à des Tabl rondes
aujourd'hui et vous allez nous rendre
compte de ces Tabl rondes ce à quoi vous
avez pu assister aujourd'hui les
thématiques que vous avez pu donc et
bien aborder aujourd'hui alors NAD on va
commencer avec vous vous avez-vous
assisté à une table ronde sur les
violences infantiles c'est bien ça
effectivement j'ai bien assisté à cette
table ronde et j'aimerais commencer par
souligner l'importance en fait de ces de
ces lieux d'échange et de formation de
sensibilisation des élus parce que c'est
une question qui est importante parce
qu'elle touche gravement et durablement
bah les enfants et que les élus peuvent
se saisir de ces questionsl vous avez pu
rencontrer qui sur sur cette thématique
assister à à quels échanges alors il y a
eu différents intervenants j'ai pu m'
échanger avec certains d'entre eux
notamment Virginie roduro qui est
adjointe à la maison de confiance et de
protection des famille des lines ou
encore Jérôme de la Croix Louis qui est
enquêteur à la brigade des mineurs de la
police de l'unité départementale à la
protection des familles donc ça c'est pe
donc pour la thématique sur les
violences infantiles de l'autre côté
pour vous messieurs Jean Tuan et
Alexandre vous avez pu vous assister à
une table ronde sur la thématique de
l'urbanisme dites-nous tout exactement
alors je rejoins exactement les les
propos de de NAD sur la question alors
je pense que c'est en tant qu'étudiant
c'est super important aussi pour pour
nous de pouvoir assister à ce ce genre
de réunion notamment aussi pour prendre
conscience de toutes les de tout
l'écosystème local quelles sont les les
préoccupations des maires comment les
parlementaires on a pu rencontrer Sophie
prima qui a également débattu sur la
question de l'Urbanisme et de
l'articulation avec le cadre législatif
de transposer ça au niveau local et je
pense que c'était aussi un moment un
moment intéressant pour nous étudiants
mais aussi pour les maires qui étaient
présents sur place qu'est-ce que vous
avez retenu vous de ces échanges ce que
j'ai retenu c'est que c'est un moment
important dans le sens où l'urbanisme en
tout cas en Île-deFrance dans ce moment
important de révision du schéma
directeur environnemental pose beaucoup
de questions c'est un sujet très
complexe et ça a été un vrai moment
d'échange et de compréhension pour
toutes et tous présents je le disait
vous avez pu interviewer Sophie prima
qui est sénatrice des on va l'écouter
tout de suite notre rôle de sénateur
c'est à la fois de faire la loi mais de
s'inspirer pour faire la loi de ce qui
se passe dans nos territoires donc 348
sénateurs de l'ensemble de la France qui
couvre la diversité de nos territoires
donc nous avons une diversité qui en
fait nous permet en tout cas on le
souhaite d'avoir une législation qui
tient compte de la diversité de la
France évidemment mon rôle il d'être en
lien avec l'ensemble des communes
l'ensemble des structures territoriales
et de comprendre en fait les difficultés
que que rencontre les élus à la fois
dans l'application de la loi mais aussi
des différentes problématiques qui
s'offrent à eux et parfois des
injonctions contradictoires de l'État
alors je précise d'ailleurs que même si
on a rajouté le petit bandeau avec le
nom et prénom de Sophie prima vous AZ
aussi réaliser le montage de de cette
interview racontez-nous qu'est-ce que
vous allez retenir de cette journée
au-delà des thématiques que vous avez pu
aborder le fait de se glisser dans la
peau d'un d'un journaliste territorial
on va dire aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça vous a fait nadèj
c'était très intense comme journée et
très intéressant parce que il y avait
une multitude de sujets qui é abordé et
ça recoupe comme jeanuan en a l'a dit
tout à l'heure toutes les thématiques
qui sont touchées par les mares les élus
euh de des ivelines et des haut France
et des haut scènes pardon des haut
scènes et euh et du coup c'était très
intéressant de passer du côté
journaliste c'est-à-dire poser les
questions voir comment ils réagissent
dans cette dynamique là de
questions-réponsse ça va c'était pas
trop difficile d'appréhender très
rapidement le montage l'interview
jeanuine pour pour le montage je
laisserai la parole à Alexandre qui a
qui a réalisé intégralement les moutages
que que vous venez de voir non je pense
que c'é c'était aussi un une façon de de
voir les choses différemment de passer
derrière la caméra pour une fois de pas
simplement être derrière son écran et
véritablement de prendre conscience de
ce que c'est que le travail de
journaliste et et pour le coup c'est
c'est pas uniquement ce qu'on peut voir
à travers un écran c'est tout travail de
préparation de montage derrière et et
puis aussi de de de sollicitation des
élus parce que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on a on a la chance qu'il soit
accessible on peut leur poser des
questions et voilà il faut faut faut
aussi faut aussi trouver les les bonnes
choses à dire et je pense que c'était
aussi unee intensité qui était assez
intéressante pour les étudiants
Alexandre pour terminer ouais en un mot
c'est la polyvalence peut-être un
deuxième mot la réactivité qui fond de
le travail qu'on a eu à faire
aujourd'hui et c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'on s'est attiré la la sympathie de
nombreux élus parce que retrouver
peut-être en nous cette volonté
d'accompagner à la fois les sujets de
comprendre les volontés des élus et
voilà d'avoir cette cette adaptation au
quotidien bravo à vous Alexandre jeanuan
et nadèj merci d'avoir participé avec
nous Vous confirmez une près d'une
trentaine d'étudiants qui ont participé
avec nous de sur SP Saint-Germain oui
tout à fait une trentaine d'étudiants et
je tiens à dire je me suis un peu baladé
au niveau des stands et je vous ai vu un
peu courir un peu de partout un grand
bravo à vous tous parce que c'était pas
facile d'aborder les personnes sur les
stand et également d'aller voir les
tables rondes donc scienp saint-germ je
le rappelle qui était partenaire de tv78
pour cette journée aux universités des
mairies de l'Ouest parisien on va faire
à présent le point dans le 78 sur le
reste des actualités du jour à rotinard
dans les
iblines c'est avec vous Michell et cette
édition de l'umob 2023 2023 est aussi
l'occasion pour certains maires
d'interpell sur des problématiques ce
mardi 10 octobre Philippe guigen maire
des clés sousbois saisi dans un courrier
le président de la République dans cette
lettre le maire divivers droite
interpelle Emmanuel Macron sur ses
déclarations les mécanismes des régimes
fiscaux qui régissent les collectivités
territoriales le 24 septembre dernier le
président avait déclaré lors d'une
interview sur TF1 et France 2 que
l'augmentation de la taxe foncière
n'était pas décidée par le gouvernement
mais les communes une position
inacceptable pour Philippe guigan dans
ce communiqué il y a notre réprobration
par rapport à ces propos il y a un
constat sur la situation actuelle
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus
d'autonomie financière dans les communes
alors qu'en fait c'est l'un des articles
72 de la Constitution aujourd'hui nous
sommes face à une uniquement un une
recette fiscale qui est contribué par
les propriétaires ce qui est une pour
nous totalement inéquitable puisque si
je prends l'exemple de ma commune d'clé
sous-bois et c'est à peu près le même
exemple dans notre commune j'ai à peu
près 65 % de la population
qui pe l'impôt alors que c'est 100 % et
heureusement de la population qui
bénéficie des services
publics le maire des clés sou ainsi que
les 11 autres de 51 ont profité de
l'umop pour engager des discussions
Philippe guigen les invite maintenant
engager avec l'État une réforme des
mécanismes financiers toujours aux
universités des mairies une remise des
trophées à laquelle nous avons assisté
ce matin celle du prix
interdépartemental de l'innovation
urbaine Attin pour cette 5e édition les
lauréat ont été distingués pour les
projets urbains innovants des villes
dans quatre catégories parmi elles
l'innovation architecturale et paysagère
ou encore l'innovation écologique dans
cette catégorie l'agglomération de 550
an et la ville de voisin bretenau ont
été récompensé pour le projet de
l'écoquartier du parc du lac également
connu comme Zac de la remise c'est la
récompense d'un travail de longue haline
et puis ça marque aussi la
reconnaissance du soin qu'on a apporté à
à ce quartier pour qu'il soit soit un
vrai écoquartier donc avec beaucoup
d'espace vert avec beaucoup d'arbres
avec des des qualités environnementales
importante avec une crèche qui va être
chauffée à la géothermie par exemple
mais également des appartements chauffés
avec le système carnoau avec des
qualités d'isolation des bâtiments pour
que les habitants n'aient pas une une
note une d'électricité ou de gaz trop
importante d'autres communes ziblinois
se sont à distinguer à cher
auberganville Saint-Germain en lait ou
encore BIF faisait partie des lauréat de
cette édition pour leur projet une
information maintenant qui concerne le
quartier du valfouré à mont-lajolie et
plus précisément la mairie annexe de la
ville qui va s'installer dans les locaux
de la caisse d'allocation familiale du
valfouret à deux pas de l'ancienne
mairie incendiée pendant les ameux de
fin juin jusque-l la mairie annexe avait
établi domicile à l'hôtel de ville mais
pour assurer un service de proximité et
réduire les déplacements des habitants
une nouvelle délocalisation était
nécessaire pour leur quelques travaux
minimes reste à faire la mairie annexe
devrait être investir ses nouveaux
locaux le 2 novembre prochain quant à la
CAF elle investira de nouveaux locaux à
800 m de là rue Gutenberg le public sera
accueilli dès le 24 octobre on termine
avec un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer
demain jeudi à Versailles effectivement
je m' je m'emmèle un petit peu dans dans
mes fiches je vais y arriver la ville
organise un salon dédié à l'emploi et à
l'entrepreneuriat des femmes l'objectif
faire rencontrer une trentaine
d'entreprises et d'associations qui ont
des postes à pourvoir avec des femmes à
la recherche d'un emploi en reconversion
ou en création d'entreprise salon est
organisé par la ville de Versailles en
collaboration avec l' PEC l'association
pour l'emploi des cadres pour l'emploi
ou encore la ville du chénéau cancour
l'année dernière le rendez-vous avait
rassemblé 362 femmes si vous êtes
intéressé rendez-vous le 12 octobre d 9h
à l'hôtel de ville de Versailles merci
Michel pour ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous êtes
témoin d'une information qui vous fait
réagir dans les evelines n'hésitez pas à
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news
direction 50 an nieline le groupe
Renault nous a ouvert ses portes il y a
quelques jours pour l'inauguration de
son nouveau bâtiment au technoocentre
agu en cours ce site abrite désormais le
plus grand simulateur de conduite
immersif au monde roads le numérique
apporte un géant au géant de
l'automobile une réduction du temps et
aussi sur le coût de développement le
reportage de vous Michel ça va on va
tester concepts de son siège je sais ce
qu'il fait c'est le plus grand
simulateur de ce type au monde le
Technocentre Renault a ouvert depuis le
printemps dernier roads un bâtiment de
2300 m car qui regroupe plusieurs
espaces de simulation Road c'est un
simulateur de
conduite ça veut dire que c'est un
système qui nous permet de tester les
voitures dans des conditions réelles
avant que les voitures existent et qui
vont permettre de simuler le
fonctionnement de la voiture en
condition réelle avec un système
d'écran qui permet de projeter c'est une
scène donc confiration une route en
conditions réell et vous allez tester
des comportements routiers ce concentrer
de technologie permet de réduire les
coûts de 50 % tout en gagnant du temps
grâce à l'immersion Renault mobilise
moins de personnes sur le terrain pour
les tests l'entreprise produit moins de
prototypes et développe des véhicules
fiables en série l'objectif c'est
d'abord
d'améliorer la vitesse de développement
d'améliorer la qualité des prestations
va donner à nos clients et également de
pouvoir tester en toute sécurité des
conditions je dirais extrêmes par
exemple vous pouvez simuler le même jour
des conditions avec une forte adhérence
quand il fait beau et une condition avec
de la neige sur la route et régler votre
comportement ou votre géométrie de train
par exemple 70 personnes travaillent
dans ce nouveau bâtiment des pièces sont
déjà testées sur ce site pour les
prochains véhicules de la marque le
premier véhicule 100 % ro devrait être
quant à lui commercialisé
2025 la technologie se met aussi au
service de l'autonomie Maria letao est
non voyante elle est atteinte d'une
rétinite pigmentaire depuis l'âge de 16
ans et grâce à un boîtier une canne à
détection d'obstacles son déficit
sensoriel et plus simples à vivre au
quotidien cette habitante de gu encour
nous a reçu chez elle Julien
Leroi expérience dira-t-il plus tard
entreud
humourque les progrès numériques pour
plus d'acc
mariao 59 ans est originaire de Guille
en cours non voyante cette femme a
développé un grand intérêt pour les
nouvelles technologies au service du
handicap détecteur de couleur machine à
lire ou thermomètre vocalisé au total
près d'une dizaine d'outils lui facilite
la vie au quotidien et permettent de
limiter l'utilisation du brail c'est de
mieux en mieux parce que avant on avait
les appareils qui lisaient mais ça
faisait vraiment robotique que là on
dirait presque une voix humaine qui
parle ce boîtier électronique fixé sur
une CAN classique se connecte en
Bluetooth au smartphone il délivre des
informations sonores dans son casque à
conduction
osseuse c'est que ça nous détecte les
bah tous les obstacles et ça nous évite
de bah de foncer dedans avec la canne
que la canne les touche Maria est
quelqu'un de très curieuse qui qui a
envie en fait de de découvrir les choses
donc c'est vrai que à ce niveau-là les
les nouvelles technologies en fait lui
permet d'être le plus aut possible
atteintte d'une rétinite pigmentaire la
quincagénè a commencé à perdre la vue
dès l'âge de 16 ans les innovations
numériques l'aident à mieux vivre son
handicap mais ne remplace pas son animal
jaik bon c'est c'est bien la canne pour
ceux qui veulent pas de chien c'est très
bien mais le même trajet qu'on va faire
avec la canne en en 20 minutes avec le
chien on peut le faire en 5 10 minutes
parce que la canne on doit chercher la
porte on doit chercher les passages
piétau on doit chercher on doit chercher
tout ça que le chien on lui demande et
et elle nousène direct à l'avenir Maria
aimerait acquérir des lunettes à
intelligence artificielle pour notamment
reconnaître les visages et lire les
panneaux de signalisation un appareil
novateur mais son coût de plusieurs
milliers d'euros est pour le moment un
frein pour cette
technophile la suite de l'actualité des
ivelines dans un instant on va
révolutionner quelque peu le programme
du 78 et passer tout de suite à notre
partie
invitée
le 78 qui se délocalise je vous le
rappelle aujourd'hui aux universités des
mairies de l'Ouest parisien qui se sont
tenus aux pyramides du port Marley alors
parmi les thématiques abordées
aujourd'hui forcément une qui est dans
toutes les têtes les têtes des élus cell
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024 qui donc s'approche désormais
avec plusieurs épreuves dans les
ivelines et on va en parler avec notre
invité qui nous a rejoint sur le plateau
c'est Olivier de laaffire bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes conseiller
départemental des zblines délégué au
sports et aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympique c'est très important de de
le préciser je aussi je je présente un
autre une autre personne qui est venue
en plateau avec nous c'est Jul Marie
bonsoir bonsoir Jul alors vous vous êtes
aussi étudiant à scienp Saint-Germain en
comme vos autres camarades qui étaient
avec nous tout à l'heure et vous avez
d'ailleurs vous suivi un peu plus les
sujets liés aux Jeux Olympiques c'est ça
aujourd'hui au sport dans les ielin
c'est ça j'ai pu suivre la table ronde
auquelle monsieur a participé et auquel
d'autres intervenants ont participé
ainsi que des interventions extérieures
notamment de d'adjoint maire ou
d'habitants de communes des Yvelines
alors une première question dites-nous
quel est l'engouement là on est
désormais alors c'est encore il y a
encore beaucoup de jours avant les Jeux
Olympiques 289 mais voilà c'est moins
d'un an désormais pour ces Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 mais je crois que oui effectivement
on sent quand même l'engouement démarrer
on a eu un un fabuleux événement euh il
y a pas plus tard qu'une quinzaine de
jours sur la colline d'lancour euh à
Saint-Quentin en Éveline avec
l'inauguration euh de la colline des
lancours et c'était un test c'était un
premier test je crois que c'est c'était
la démonstration un petit peu ou la
finalité de tout le travail qu'on a pu
avoir avec toutes les collectivités avec
tous les acteurs du sport pendant
pendant maintenant plusieurs années hein
pour préparer les Jeux et ça y est je
crois qu'on arrive dans le concret donc
on voit les jeux les jeux arriés on est
encore dans l'organisation on avait on
encore un certain nombre de réunions
mais mais on voit le concret arriver et
on voit l'engouement quand même aussi
arriver où on a vu finalement tous ces
spectateurs qui sont venus aussi euh
pour la première fois sur la colline des
lancour je crois que ça a été ça a été
révélateur aussi euh peut-être du
démarrage des jeux dans les evelines oui
j'en profite puisque vous parlez de ce
test even qui a lieu sur la la colline
des lencours côté sportif ça a été une
réussite on a une double victoire
française côté organisation quel est le
bilan que vous dressez alors c'était
c'était l'objectif hein c'était de voir
comment justement on on pouvait gérer
les flux comment on allait accueillir
euh toutes les personnes qui arrivaient
sur la colline ça s'est plutôt bien
passé de cet aspect là je crois que on
peut c'était plutôt une réussite et je
crois que la réussite aussi qui a été
fort de cette colline c'est c'est le la
vie aussi de des des des des
participants enfin des des des athlètes
qui ont trouvé le le le le parcours très
technique mais mais à la fois somptueux
et je crois que cette colline où on
donnait pas grand-chose encore il y a
quelques années sur pour cette colline
est devenue vraiment une réussite
sportive et et je pense que ça deviendra
demain un site emblématique des Yvelines
pour le sport Michel pour préciser 3000
spectateurs sur le Test Event à en cours
5000 personnes sur site parce qu'il faut
compter les médias l'organisation les
bénévoles et les spectateurs donc 5000
personnes sur site pendant ce ce Test
Event il y en aura trois fois plus lors
des Jeux olympiques de 2024 donc qui ont
marqué une la fin d'une première phase
de travaux on peut le dire sur la la
colline d'élancour côté travaux il y a
aussi le site d'équitation au au sein du
château de versaill du parc du château
de versaill on en est où concrètement
aujourd'hui les travaux aussi c'est pas
visible par contre pour l'instant c'est
pas visible pour l'instant c'est pas
encore visible parce que effectivement
tout ce qui est gradin et tout ce qui va
être pour le le concours épique et pour
le et pour le dressage n'est pas monté
mais on a commencé à faire le parcours
du concours complet qui va être dans le
château il y a eu des tests qui ont été
fait aussi cet été dans le château
justement pour tester le le le parcours
il y a deux passages sur la sur le grand
canal donc ça va être aussi assez
fabuleux en terme d'image en terme de de
spectacle aussi ce qui ce qui est sympa
en fait dans ces sports de nature comme
le comme le le VTT c'est que en fait
aussi on est dehors et tout le monde va
pouvoir bouger sur l'événement pourir
aller voir les a obstacles les
différents obstacles c'est c'est c'est
des ça va êre des sports très actifs et
à la fois très très dynamique aussi
puisque il y aura justement cette
facilité de pouvoir aussi aller aller
voir et se déplacer mais je pense que
sincèrement les travaux avancent bien et
et je pense sincèrement on a encore de
très beaux jeux aussi à versaill dans le
dans le château de dans le dans le parc
du château de versaill juste avant que
Jules puisse vous poser une question
justement quel est le rôle du Conseil
départemental dans la préparation de ces
Jeux Olympiques et paralympiqu en ce
moment ben déjà le le premier premier
j'ai envie de dire c'est qu'on était un
financeurin le le département et le
partenaire des collectivités de toutes
les communes et effectivement on a
soutenu tous les projets dans dans dans
dans les dans les communes d'abord
olympiques notamment à 5 en Yveline
puisqu'on a soutenu à plus de 7 millions
d'euros le le le projet de la colline
d'lencour on a soutenu effectivement ça
c'était avant j'ai envie de dire mais on
a soutenu aussi la construction du
Vélodrome l'accompagnement également du
Golf National donc on a été vraiment un
partenaire financier je pense aussi dans
dans le dans le dans le le l'aménagement
olympique des Yvelines et puis après
encore un peu plus avec les les centres
de préparation au jeux où on a eu des
politiques justement pour aider les
communes à améliorer rendre accessible
les les les sites les sites sportifs de
leur commune et puis j'ai envie de dire
aujourd'hui on va travailler pour faire
que demain les jeux nous servent à
quelque chose qu'on a un héritage derère
VO et je pense que le premier héritage
qu'on aura c'est de pouvoir amener de
pouvoir avoir amener tous les ivelinois
à aller faire du sport parce qu'on aura
des sites parce qu'on a amélioré i les
sites et puis aussi parce qu'on a voulu
avec nos 15 ambassadeurs qu'on a nommé
aussi dans le département pour aller
promouvoir le sport je pense qu'on a
aussi cette envie aussi de pouvoir aller
dire au aux Français et même et d'abord
aux ivelinois et bien écoutez voilà on a
des sportifs on a des Champions et ben
cela on va on mettre les moyens pour les
aider pour que demain aussi ils nous
ramènent des médailles parce que je
crois que c'est bien aussi de mettre de
l'argent pour dans les sites olympique
et dans les sites dans les dans dans
l'investissement mais c'est bien aussi
ça sera bien aussi demain si on ramène
des médailles pour pour les ivinois pour
ravir aussi les nos ivelinois et c'est
important quand même de maintenir cet
investissement cet engagement malgré le
contexte contraint inflation baisse des
dotations également j'ai j'ai pas dit
qu'on pourrait peut-être continuer après
2025 mais mais au moins ce qu'on aura pu
faire avant les Jeux et puis encore une
fois la dynamique on a sucrée grâce aux
Jeux Olympiques parce que finalement
grâce aux Jeux Olympiques on a réussi à
à à changer un peu nos façons de de de
travailler on a rendu le sport très
visible on s'est rendu compte que le
sport était aussi important parce que
final finalement ça touche un peu tous
les publics le sport et et on s'est
attelé nous au département à le faire
aussi auprès de nos publics prioritaires
que sont les personnes handicapées que
sont les personnes âgées que sont les
personnes en insertion mais qui sont
aussi nos collégiens parce que le le
département agit aussi pour les collèges
et donc on essayie vraiment de
travailler pour no public et faire que
demain tous ces gens-là puissent aller
faire du sport et donc nos collégiens
ils ont un passe plus ils vont pouvoir
aller faire du sport avec 80 € et
essayer des nouveaux sports et bien tant
mieux et puis d' personnes handicapés
ben on les aide aussi à trouver des
structures pour pouvoir aller faire du
sport et développer des clubs et on
donne des moyens au clubs pour
développer des équipes parasport mais
voilà j'ai envie de dire c'est toutes
ces petites missions qu'on a réussi
aussi à créer grâce à l'engouement des j
mais je pense que c'est toutes ces
petites missions qui vont faire que
demain et bien justement on aura pu
valoriser le sport pour que demain on
ait encore plus de personnes all pour
aller faire du sport alors la parole à
Jul Marie étudiant à sciencespst
Saint-Germain merci alors pour rebondir
sur la question de l'héritage justement
que les GIR les GI pourront donner aux
départements aux ivelinois et notamment
aux personnes en situation d' handicap
que vous avez évoqué où les personnes Pr
prioritaire de manière plus générale
vous avez évoqué pendant la table ronde
l'impulsion que peut donner les j dans
l'investissement des communes notamment
dans des infrastructures mais aussi
l'investissement qu'elles peuvent avoir
dans le champ du handicap qui est saisi
mais peut-être pas assez peut-être
jamais assez quel sera l'héritage des
JO sur ce sujet sur ces sujetsl pardon
et comment le département peut
accompagner justement les cunes sur le
temps long avec justement cette
impulsion des Jos qu'on espère sur qui
pas sur le temps long ce que ce que j'ai
voulu faire moi c'est déjà d'arrêter un
peu les subventions systématiques qu'on
pouvait donner à tous les clubs et et et
du coup de retravailler des projets avec
les clubs et donc on s'est mis autour de
la table avec tous les acteurs les
comités départementaux les les communes
les clubs les fédérations pour essayer
de voir comment on pouvait avancer aussi
ensemble et je pense que c'était ça
aussi la base c'était de savoir
travailler ensemble et essayer de
trouver des solutions et moi ce que j'ai
aussi demandé c'est on va voir les les
les Jeux paralympiques il faut qu'on
sache travailler aussi sur le sur le
handicap et qu' on sache faire des
choses aussi et proposer des solutions
sur le handicap et donc déjà on va aider
tous les clubs à créer des équipes
paralympi para pardon par sport dans
leur dans leur club c'est un moyen
financier supplémentaire qu'on va
pouvoir leur apporter on va aider aussi
les athlètes paralympiqu pardon les
athlètes
parasport pour aussi aller dans ces
aller aussi pouvoir faire faire du sport
permettre aussi au clubs d'acheter du
matériel parce que ça coûte cher
d'acheter des fauteuils parce que ça
coûte cher d'acheter du matériel ça
c'est une dynamique qu'on a qu'on a
lancé dans le territoire éinois et puis
il y a quelque chose aussi qui est
important c'est que on va aussi
accueillir dans les Yvelines et ça c'est
vraiment une une une on va dire une
spécificité linoise d'accueillir l'ISPC
l'Institut de santé parasport connecté
con qui sera une sorte d'inp de
l'andisport finalement c'est exactement
ça et en fait ça va être ça va être le
l'idée c'est de de de donner des outils
à toutes les personnes handicapées pour
aller faire du sport donc c'est une
prothèse donc c'est un équipement c'est
un fauteuil voilà c'est trouver la
solution pour que chaque personne
handicapée puisse aller faire du sport
et ça ça sera dans les evvelines ça
c'est pour moi quelque chose de magique
et ben ça ça sera ça fait partie de
l'héritage pour moi yvelinois demain
après les J et on le rappelle pour
terminer plusieurs sites olympiques le
vélodrome national à 50 ans le Stadium
de BMX toujours à 50 ans comme le Golf
National la colline d'élencour le
château de versaill et aussi le tracé
des épreuves de cyclisme sur route qui
passe Parin et du marathon également
toute dernière question très rapidement
mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait la popularité
des zblin qu'est-ce qui fait que
lesblines a été choisi pour autant de
disciplines accueir autant de
disciplinees vous savez il y a une chose
qui est très amusante mais regardez le
pariniis c'est le tour de France ils
veulent terminer ou alors le pariniis
démarré et le Tour de France terminé par
les ivelines je crois que les ivelines
offrent quelque chose aussi d'assez
exceptionnel en fait on a un territoire
une chance qu'on on oublie de regarder
parfois mais finalement vous avez dans
les ivelines un peu tout vous avez un
fleuve vous avez des forêts vous avez
des des nivelés effectivement c'est plus
intéressant quand on peut avoir un peu
de difficulté aussi dans dans dans des
courses et finalement si le
parisversaill vient jusqu'à versaill
c'est bien parce qu'il y a une côte qui
est un peu compliquée si le vélo se
plaît à aller aussi ai dans la vallée de
Chevreuse c'est parce qu'il y a aussi
quelques complexités sportives et puis
on a un atout aussi supplémentaire que
personne n'a c'est on a aussi ce
patrimoine colossal et magnifique que
l'on peut avoir dans les Yvelines que ce
soit Saint-Germain poisside Versailles
rambouillé enfin je vais pas tous les
citer parce que on en a un peu partout
mais ce qui fait aussi on va pouvoir
offrir au monde des images fabuleuses et
et je crois que ça va être ça aussi la
force des evelines demain c'est de
pouvoir à la fois démontrer notre
capacité à développer le sport à
développer des infrastructures avoir des
infrastructures structurantes aussi sur
le territoire et puis avoir aussi
j'aienvie quelque chose de beau à
présenter aux français mais aussi au
monde entier merci Olivier de laaffire
conseil départemental délégué aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques également
délégué au sport merci aussi à Jules
pour pour sa question et merci à vous
également Michel elmidoro la suite du C
suite dans l'un des sites les plus
emblématiques du département c'est le
zoo safari de toiri et pour notre
rubrique Les animaux du 78 cette semaine
nous mettons à l'honneur les animaux
sauvages de ce site Linois Antoine maqu
qui est soigneur nous présente les deux
nouveaux lyonceo Sana et
[Musique]
Sarabi bonjour je m'appelle Antoine
Maquet je suis soigneur animalier ici à
Toir depuis 7 ans maintenant et je suis
là aujourd'hui pour vous présenter les
dernières naissances de Lyon de lonceau
plus précisément du coup deux petites
femelles qui s'appellent Sana et
Sarabi
[Musique]
les Lions se reproduisent très bien en
captivité il y a beaucoup de parcs à
travers la France et l'Europe en général
qui ont des lions et qui les
reproduisent donc c'est des animaux qui
se reproduisent très bien en captivité
mais c'est toujours une bonne nouelle
nouvelle d'avoir des naissances dans un
parc zoologique parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui les parcs
zoologiques vont travailler ensemble
main dans la main en France en Europe
même à travers le monde pour justement
participer à la conservation à la
préservation des espèces menacées et le
lion d'Afrique celui qui nous concerne
aujourd'hui il est classé vulnérable sur
la liste rouge de l'UCN donc c'est une
position qui est vraiment pas
confortable pour lui en Afrique dans ses
pays d'origine il va subir beaucoup de
pression notamment bien sûr
principalement à cause de l'homme il va
être chassé tué braconné et donc avoir
des naissances en parc zoologique ça va
participer justement à préserver cette
espèce qu'on pourra éventuellement un
jour
[Musique]
réintroduire tout est un peu possible
pour l'instant c'est sûr qu'on va les
garder ici à toiri avec leur maman ils
ont besoin d'elles ils vont elles vont
probablement grandir ici et puis
éventuellement un jour elles partiront
vers un autre parc zoologique parce que
les animaux sauvages qu'on a ici à toiri
en fait ne nous appartiennent pas
vraiment ils font pas partie d'un
programme d'élevage européen qu'on va
gérer comme son nom l'indique au niveau
européen et là il y a une personne qui
va décider des arrivées et des départ
des animaux pour assurer un patrimoine
génétique le plus intéressant possible
pour l'espèce donc ces deux femelles
pourront éventuellement partir vers un
autre malâ reproducteur pour comme je
vous le disais assurer un brassage
génétique
[Musique]
intéressant les petits alors ils vont
être un petit peu plus actifs que les
parents hein c'est bien connu les bébés
ils vont jouer ils vont découvrir la vie
ils vont tourner dans le grand enclos
qu'ils ont ici à disposition à toiri euh
et puis rapidement ils vont grandir et
ils vont adopter le même rythme que que
leurs parents pour l'instant ils têtent
et puis petit à petit vont se mettre à
grignoter un peu la la ration de leur
maman jusque à un moment donné on va
vraiment leur distribuer une vraie
ration rien que pour
[Musique]
eux voilà je vous ai présenter les deux
dernières naissances ici à toiri les
deux petites liones Sana et Sarabi
hésitez pas à venir les voir et les
observer ici chez nous jusqu'au 22
octobre la cave de Gal à saint-sir
l'école célèbre le vin avec les fêtes
des vendanges à versaill c'est le musée
Lambinet qui propose aux visiteurs une
visite tout en dégustant de grandes
cuvées françaises le vin qui est à
l'honneur dans les ivelines c'est un
reportage de Gabriel Gontier et si les
Yvelines aussi était une terre de vin
alors que les vendanges battent leur
plein à sincir l'école la cave de Gali
propose jusqu'au 22 octobre la fête des
vendanges au programme découverte et
dégustation l'opération de la Fête des
vendanges est destiné à nous caler sur
la période des vendanges qui a lieu dès
la mi à fin août jusqu'à en général mi à
fin septembre et en quelque sorte de
mettre en place une opération de foire
au vin l'idée justement est de est de
dénicher des étiquettes qui sortte un
petit peu du lot parmi ces vins de
nombreuses cuvé pour tous les goûts
blanc rosé au rouge près de 400 référen
régulièrement renouvelées sont proposées
pour tous les budgets il ne vous reste
plus qu'à
déguster et si sa saveur est parfois
imprévisible les lieux de dégustation
peuvent également réserver quelques
surprise vous voyez que c'est un petit
peu doré comme en réalité la pierre
blanche elle Estelle elle est pas tout à
fait
blanche à Versailles le musée Lambinet
propose des soirées à révin une visite
sensorielle ou l'histoire du vin se mêle
à celle de l'art une sélection qui
demande donc une attention particulière
je l'ai choisi un peu comme un repas
c'est-à-dire il y a une trame là par
exemple on va déguster plutôt des vins
qu'on buvait à la belle époque en
général le premier vin c'est un vin
effervescent pour éveiller pour donc il
s'appelle un champagne pour accueillir
les gens puis y a tout un beaucoup
d'histoires sur le champagne et puis
après un vin blanc un vin rosé un vin
rouge et un vin doux et pour mettre
l'essence à l'épreuve tout au long de la
visite les vins sont cachés pour laisser
libre cours à l'imagination et au palais
des visiteurs donc là en fait je vais
vous servir et hop vous rentrerez dans
l'espace suivant un vin d'Alsace pour
commencer et pour profiter pleinement du
vin quoi de mieux que de contempler les
œuvres qui ont inspiré leur sélection
allier les deux ça permet notamment à
des personnes qui sont pas forcément
familiers en fait du monde des musées
des de l'art mais qui aiment le vin de
se rendre au musée donc l'idée aussi
c'est de capapter un public de non et
aussi de proposer un autre regard pour
les personnes qui connaissent bien en
fait ben les collections du musée et qui
ont envie tout simplement bah plutôt de
découvrir les vins ça va dans les deux
sens l'occasion unique de mettre à
l'honneur le savoir-faire viticol
français tout en trinquant avec Madame
Lambinet et on rappelle bien sûr que
l'alcool est à consommer avec modération
juste avant de vous laisser on va
regarder les prévisions météo de
demain demain jeudi la la météo est
toujours plus estivale cotonale dans les
Yvelines des éclaircis dans votre Ciel
yvelinois demain matin avec 17°r à
Versailles et mon la jolie 16°r à Oudan
15 à Rambouillet dans l'après-midi le
temps se gâte avec un ciel nuageux côté
température prévoyez 23°gr dans le
secteur centre des zvelines alors plutôt
21 et 22°gr même et vous voyez 22°gr
mentre la jolie et 21°gr du côté de
Rambouillet et demain jeudi 12 octobre
nous fêterons les Wilfried voilà c'est
la fin de ce 78 merci de nous avoir
suivi je vous le rappelle le 78 était
enregistré aujourd'hui et depuis les
universités des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien l'événement se tenait aux
pyramides de portmly demain jeudi
nouvelle édition du 78 retour dans
d'autre plateau traditionnel d'ici là
passer une très belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78